hello everyone so welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily it's always
been my dream to be a speaker and I quit
my day job in order to work and mentor
under Evansville time and all of you are
coming along for the ride with me so in
every episode I take on a different
challenge that really sent my comfort
zone all in order to help me grow as a
speaker so my challenge this time is to
take a deep dive into the three speakers
that I resonated with the most so they
are Tony Robbins Brittany Brown and
simon Sinek I'm going to try to
understand what are the things that they
did to get to with you today as well as
the important lessons that I learned
from each one of them number one is Tony
Robbins he's an author speaker and a
peak performance coach
so I'm Tony Robbins was only 17 years
old he met a man by the name of Jim Rohn
who was a motivational speaker
so when Tony Robbins first got started
he didn't she tried to figure out
everything on his own instead he went
and mentored under Jim Rohn he what made
Jim successful so that way he can apply
the same actions and same be easier to
himself as well some of the things miss
Michelle taught me starting at age 25 I
had a dear dear friend and mentor named
Jim Rohn who was my teacher when I was
17 years old he's somebody I sent out
some videos I'll probably attach some
things to the city or another one about
him just to honor him and his teachings
but he gave me a way of looking at life
and allowed me to not ask life would be
easier but to ask could I be better
he got me to realize that the secret to
life was to work harder on myself than
my job or anything else because then I'd
have something to give people and he
really shaped me and he just passed away
and I was thinking wow I'm going to be
49 years old I met him when I was 17
think of the fact that my journey is
just beginning and think of all the
impact of just a couple ideas out of my
life and I want to really continue to do
that for you or anybody you care about
so so after working and mentoring under
Jim Rohn 20 Robbins went on to doing his
own seminars as well but he didn't get
his actual breakthrough until he cured a
woman from her lifelong snake phobia
live on stage there's a famous story
about something up a god name but it was
if somebody had some kind of phobia
wilwayco a phobia and then for seven
years and you did it in 15 minutes yeah
and but what made my career was I was
attacked by the psychiatrist on the
radio saying you're a liar you're a
charlatan people like you should not be
allowed on the radio you can't do this
and so I was a real level frankly I was
like in a space saying great are you a
scientist if you are then test your
hypothesis give me your patient I'll be
at the Holiday Inn tomorrow night so it
was like the shootout and it was like a
movie he brought her I wiped it out I
wrapped the snake around her a phobia is
an uncontrollable physical response to
some stimulus you know it's not just
fear it's shaking spitting and dangerous
only funny worked on it for seven years
so that became my signature was to
challenge and then gradually I grew
because I was really just trying to
prove to everybody and myself as well
that I was worthy rather than you know
maturing a little bit and just knowing
that there are skill sets that are
valuable for everybody so what Tony
Robbins taught me that success leaves
Clues similar to what Tony Robbins did
with Jim Brown is what I am doing with
Evan which is why I quit my very safety
very comfortable well-being day job
spent full time hours with Evan even
though a lot of our days are spent not
talking to each other because we're
working on another project I do is I
actually study everything that Evans
does how does you set up this day how
does the interact with people how does
he problem-solve and everything else in
between because I'm trying to look for
clues myself and patterns and behaviors
so that way I could write all of that to
myself and achieves a similar kind of
success that Evan has to the number two
is Rene's Brown she is an author speaker
and a research professor so when Britney
and brown started out on her journey as
a researcher she quickly realized the
importance of having the courage to show
up and be seen vulnerability is not
about winning it's not about losing it's
about having the courage to show up and
be seen it's about willingness to say
look I don't have all the answers
this is daring greatly for me I'm
wearing false eyelashes
my biggest fear when they put them on
was like am I going to get halfway
through this thing and be like I do just
rip the whole thing off that's happen to
me before
Oh let's rip them both off and there you
are make it before the one you making it
here today yeah so I mean I think you
know people tell me all the time I don't
want to be vulnerable I don't want to do
this because I can't bear this and I
think being vulnerable feels dangerous
and I think it feels scary and I think
it is terrifying but I don't think it's
as dangerous scary or terrifying as
getting to the end of our lives and
wondering what if I would have shown up
what if I would have said has been added
yeah yeah that to me is what daring
greatly is the brené Brown continued to
teach as well as do research at the
University of Houston but it wasn't
until her popular TEDx talk the power
vulnerability that received over 30
million views that kind of pulled her
into the star that she is today
what underpinned this shame this I'm not
good enough which we all know that
feeling
I'm not blank enough I'm not thin enough
rich enough beautiful and that's smart
enough promoted enough the thing that
underpinned us was excruciating
vulnerability this idea of an order for
connection to happen we have to allow
ourselves to be seen really seen and you
know how I feel about vulnerability I
hate vulnerability and so I thought this
is my chance to beat it back with my
measuring stick I'm going in I'm going
to figure this stuff out I'm going to
spend a year I'm going to totally
deconstruct shame I'm going to
understand how vulnerability work and
I'm going to outsmart it so I was ready
and I was really excited as you know
it's not going to turn out well
you know that so what Britney Brown
taught me is that I need to have the
courage to show up there's so many
things I'm afraid because I'm concerned
that people are going to judge me and
criticize me but the reality is I want
to be a speaker I want to be able to
inspire people through my work which
means I need to get outside of my
comfort zone and do the briefing and be
courageous so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go into the biggest
intersection in Toronto Yonge and Dundas
Square and film in front of everyone
even though I am so scared even thinking
about to do it what I need to do because
I need to be brave and have the courage
to show up
number three is simon Sinek he's an
author leadership guru and a speaker so
simon Sinek first started out by owning
his own business but he completely lost
passion for what he did which caused him
to look inward and to find his life and
I realized I knew what I did it was good
at it and I knew how I did it I could
tell you what was different or special
about the way I did things but I
couldn't tell you why I was doing it
that was the missing piece you have to
have all three I became obsessed with
this thing called the why I figured out
how to find my why and that restored my
passion to levels I had never
experienced before and more importantly
I figured out how to help others find
theirs and I did what anyone would do
when you discover something beautiful
you share with your friends and my
friend started making crazy life changes
themselves and they started finding
happiness and passion that they'd never
experienced before it was me solving my
own problem that happened to help others
sold it for them to when simon Sinek
found his why he started helping friends
and friends of friends find their wise
as well but it wasn't until his
extremely popular TEDx talk start with
why which has over 32 million views to
date that launches career into becoming
a best-selling author as well as a
consultant to major companies around the
world but if you don't know why you do
what you do and people respond to why
you do which
then how will anybody how will you ever
get people to vote for your buy
something from you or more importantly
be loyal and want to be a part of what
it is what that you do again the goal is
not just as to sell people who need what
you have the goal is to sell to people
who believe what you believe what simon
Sinek taught me is that I need to start
with my why and my why is to inspire
people to be extraordinary so going
forward all the meetings I have all the
interactions I have all the phone calls
I have I'm going to start with my wife
so over the next few weeks I'm going to
be taking on different challenges based
on the lessons that I learned from Tony
Renee and Simon
but Evan just gave me a surprise
challenge I'm going to participate in my
first corporate game which means that
all of you are going to come behind the
scenes in my first corporate event so
the question of the day is what is that
one lesson you learn from someone you
look up to it could be an entrepreneur
that you saw in Evans channel it could
be a teacher it could be a family member
I would love to know what that lesson is
please leave in the comments below and I
will join it on the discussion so I want
to thank you guys for watching and I
actually have a special shout out for
Pavo Liu vaneau
so powerful wrote in my last episode
that this editing is ten times better
than any TV show
honestly Pavo thank you so much for the
kind words and it's actually our
fabulous editor Christina that does an
amazing job with all our videos so
Christina high-five for a job well done
hey Luis and thank you Bob so thank you
so much for watching but more
importantly being on this journey with
me when I first started out I really
didn't know what to expect but all the
love and encouragement just kept on
pouring in that gave me the courage to
keep going on I couldn't ask for a
better community than the leaf nation to
be part of this so once again thank you
thank you so much I am so grateful I'll
see you very very soon
you